（音楽）
今日はね、やっぱ、みんな海に行っちゃうと思うんですよ～、うん
今日は俺もね、友達と、海に来てるわけなんだけども〜
まあ、海に来ちゃうと、まあ、日焼けしちゃう訳なんすよ
うん。
結構僕、焼けやすい体質なんで、
今年も、まだほら、首とかもだいぶ、
もうやばくない！？
割ともう日焼けしちゃってる感じなんだけども、
せっかく海に来てね、
これからガンガン日焼けしていくわ￥！＞♂×ですけれども〜
今日は、ひとつ
特別なね
実験的なことをしてみようと思ってる
そ〜う
日焼けを促進させるこういうのがあります
小麦色に綺麗に焼ける
この、なんていうの、
サンタンローション
お肌に優しく日焼けができるっていうやつがあります
どす黒いですけどねw
これやばいでしょ、多分
タンニングウォーターっつって、体がね、すごい
なんだろう、濃い
濃い日焼け、濃い日焼けができるってやつがあります
まあ、こういう日焼けを促進させるものがあって、
日焼けしたくない人はこういうのを使うんですよね、逆に
UVカットつってね
SPF50＋の星4つ、
全く日焼けしなくなります
こういう紫外線をカットして、白い肌を保てるやつもある訳なんですよね〜
俺は
考えついちゃった訳さ
もっとカッコ良くありたい
こっち側は美白的な、こう綺麗な白い肌の男子
で、こっちからこっち半分は・・・
こう小麦色のちょっと健康的な、夏的な男子
こっち半分半分で、こう
こっち側の俺と、こっち側の◎△＄％俺
二面性を楽しめるね
２つの顔を持つ男に、今日はなろうと思います。
まずこっち側半分に、日焼け止め系を塗っていきます
うわっ
うわ、間違えた！
（スプレーを吹きかける音）
よし、OKです
はい、こっち半分は、ちょっと待ってwwもはやだよね
こっち半分は今のところ完璧なコーティングがされてるので
多分、今回は日焼けしないと思います
じゃあ、こっち側半分
日焼けしやすいように塗っていきます
日焼け用乳液。まず体に、塗っていきま〜す
全然白い
はい、じゃあさらにもっと黒くなるように、
濃い日焼けが楽しめる、
タンニングウォーターも、これも塗っていきます
よっしゃあ
え、どう、見た感じ分かる？
あんま分かんないっしょ
はい
はい、というわけで一応ですね
こっち側半分が日焼けする側
こっち側半分が日焼け止めを塗った側
白と黒が楽しめるようになると思います
では、日焼け行ってきます！
（はじめのくしゃみ）
よ〜し焼けるぞ〜
（風の音）
（音楽）
2つの顔を持つ男
それが俺！！（ﾄﾞﾔｯ）
（エンディング曲）
どうかな〜